seven months after the initial release
of battlefield 2042 the first content
season for the multiplayer only first
person shooter is finally hitting the
game
season one zero hour comes alongside a
huge number of adjustments and fixes as
well as new content
it gives a sense of how developer dice
is working to change the tenor of the
game in some significant ways from how
maps are laid out to how specialists
convey their personalities on post-game
victory screens zero hour launches for
all players on june 9th but gamespot got
a chance to spend a couple hours playing
with some of its new content additions
during a preview event this week that
session put us on exposure the new map
coming to battlefield 2042 available to
all players exposure feels like it sets
a different tone from some of bf 2042's
other maps with a host of differing
locations and a focus on verticality
that goes beyond what we've previously
seen in the game exposure is set in the
canadian rocky mountains where a
landslide has collapsed part of a
military facility opening up chunks of
the base russia-backed forces are
invading hoping to uncover whatever
secrets are inside and with portions of
the base literally ripped apart by a
falling mountain they have plenty of
means to enter because exposure centers
on a cliff side there are key locations
and entry and exit points that are
accessible by parachute or wingsuit and
ziplines have been set up all over the
area at the top of the map is a flat
zone with structures and containers
ringing the open mouth of the landslide
creating long sight lines and forcing
infantry to circle around to get where
they're going on the other side leap off
the cliff however and you can glide down
to attack the interior of the base which
is set into the mountain like a super
villain's lair at the bottom of the
landslide is wreckage and a few control
points for use in conquest mode we
played both breakthrough and conquest on
exposure with the former mode using a
smaller portion of the map and confining
its player count to 64. the smaller
breakthrough approach is reflective of
one of bf2042's biggest changes going
forward dice says it's unshackling its
all-out warfare modes from its previous
128 player count and will instead be
focusing on somewhat smaller maps with
more cover and density with its seasonal
releases going forward exposure and
original launch maps will still offer
128 player modes but starting in season
2 new maps will top out at 64 players
the adjustments dice has made work well
on exposure which takes advantage of
both player counts but generally feels
like it uses denser cover and varying
terrain to make for more interesting
engagements the verticality of the
terrain really helps make exposure feel
large without it also leaving you
constantly exposed and vulnerable that
seems to be a large part of dice's
design approach for new maps and it's
also bringing it to some of the old ones
dice said it's reworking some of
battlefield 2042's launch maps with the
first being kaleidoscope the huge map
set in south korea that featured a lot
of open ground in addition to a
skyscraper littered cityscape in august
dice is releasing a revamped version
that adds new areas like a forward
operating base to certain portions while
also raising terrain and adding more
objects to provide cover like piles of
sandbags and abandoned heavy machinery
the map will also feature more
destructible elements to give players
options for dealing with that cover and
changing the map over time the egyptian
map renewal is getting an overhaul in
season 2. still while objects like
shipping crates and watchtowers give
some cover from infantry there are still
vehicles to contend with season 1 adds
two more vehicles to the roster a pair
of two-seater helicopters that sport
some interesting ways to use them in
battle both helicopters the rah-68 huron
and yg99 hannibal feature an assault
mode the standard approach of buzzing
around shooting everything with a
machine gun and a stealth mode which
allows you to shirk enemy radars and
lock-ons and drop bombs on opposing
forces from above unlike other vehicles
they seem to be a little easier to bring
down for infantry so while they might
mess you up as they nimbly circle around
and go wild with machine gun fire
they're not as big a worry as a tank or
an armored personnel vehicle to combat
these new vehicular threats dice is
adding a new specialist character in
season 1 anti-vehicle engineer lis
it seems the character is especially
good at taking down airborne threats
with list sporting a teleguided missile
launcher which means you can control the
missile and fly it into your target
helicopters might sport radar-breaking
stealth but if you're less you can use
her launcher to bypass the need for any
smart tracking technology and do the
aiming yourself lis also automatically
detects vehicles on her radar with
damaged vehicles highlighted in her
vision giving you info on where to focus
your armor-busting efforts in practice
lisa's abilities came in handy at
control points where opponents were
trying to turn the tides using vehicles
although her tv launcher wasn't quite as
useful as you might think it still takes
a bunch of shots to destroy a tank for
instance while they're not especially
effective against infantry her missiles
are good for cracking through walls and
exposing enemy positions however it does
seem like the trick will be finding
effective uses for the character when
there aren't a ton of helicopters that
need grounding adding some new variety
for the rest of season 1 are two new
weapons and a new gadget to help spice
up some loadouts dice is adding a new
designated marksman rifle called the
bsvm which is like having a sniper rifle
that can also handle close combat the
gun comes with an integrated suppressor
to keep the noise down and make you
tougher for enemies to find as you fight
along with single fire and fully
automatic firing modes that means the
gun is pretty effective in all mid-range
scenarios and can easily go from picking
off distant troops as they cross a field
to handling whoever's charging you in a
tight hallway it's also a pretty fast
firing weapon so you don't necessarily
feel outclassed by assault rifles at
close range even more fun than the bsvm
though is the new ghost maker crossbow
the single firing bow has a surprisingly
long range and it's nearly silent at
closer ranges it'll generally earn you a
one hit kill provided you actually hit
what you're shooting at miss and you'll
suffer through a painfully long reload
animation that leaves you extremely
vulnerable to getting blasted by any
fast firing weapon but if you land the
hit the crossbow is incredibly
satisfying and you can even be effective
at longer ranges even though you'll have
to land two or three shots to win a
fight the crossbow was a favorite of
mine throughout our play session it's a
great weapon for stealth and its one-hit
kill effectiveness means you have a good
shot at winning fights even when you're
disadvantaged it's another addition that
feels aimed to expand on the variety on
offer in battlefield 2042 especially
when you add the option to change what
bolts it fires including an explosive
shot that can be used against vehicles
apart from the exposure map all the new
elements are coming to battlefield 22 as
part of its new battle pass which
includes a free and premium track the
free track includes 30 tiers and allows
you to earn all the new content without
paying any money which means you can
unlock the new weapons gadget
specialists and vehicles just by playing
the premium pass which costs about 10
dollars adds another 70 tiers of
cosmetic items you can advance up the
battle pass with battle pass points
which you'll get from earning experience
points by playing the game and
completing various weekly missions those
missions stay active even if you miss a
week or start the battle pass late so
you can still complete them later on
there are also bonus missions that'll
pop up throughout the season to let you
earn more points but those only stay
active for a limited time all that said
our session didn't really give any sense
of how easy or difficult earning battle
pass tiers might be dice says it plans
for its seasons to last 12 weeks which
means season 1 is likely to end on
august 31st the exposure map the new
guns and vehicles and the new
specialists help freshen up battlefield
2042 in some key ways and dice's focus
on somewhat smaller tighter maps seems
like a positive one for the game's
fundamentals we played through some
pretty fun matches while previewing
season 1 but there are a lot of changes
coming down the pike for dice's
multiplayer shooter it'll likely take
some time to see how well the game's new
content adjustments and seasonal
approach will serve battlefield 2042
over the long term